we've seen you transform four roles many
times over but performance capture is a
completely different type of
transformation so when this opportunity
came up did that give you pause or you
liked her I don't know that was a lot of
the reason I wanted to do it you know
I've seen Andy I've known him since I
was 19 is a wonderful actor and I've
seen him become the master of
performance capture watching them a
Caesar and Planet of the Apes doing
these absolutely brilliant scenes where
you completely forget that you're
watching and listening to Apes and
thinking to myself you know this this
might be the way the future you know is
there gonna be a blend of prosthetics
and things do I maybe not have to
transform if they're able to do it and
you know digitally now and things are
coming along it's a brave new world in
terms of technology so I felt like okay
he's the master of this I want to know
better person to try out than with him
and with a timeless classic like
Kipling's writings and there hasn't been
a version seen like this before the
others are great you know wonderful
musicals fairytale versions bare
necessities love them but there's never
been a version seen like this which is
true to Kipling's writings given what
you're just saying about just the
advancement of all this technology and
also bringing up Andy in the Apes movies
I was wondering what your take was on
just whether or not this kind of work
should be recognized by the Academy
because last year when Worf the Planet
of the Apes came out yeah I think and he
should have been in consideration for
Best Actor so do you see that line being
blurred I think it'll come to happen but
I think people don't understand what is
involved in performance capture yet you
know there's a lot of people I speak
with and they still don't understand
that it's not just your voice you are
actually there and you are acting with
all of the other actors as well so I
think once people understand it more
then they will start to recognize it
more so performance capture highs and
lows for you what was the best part
about being able to bring a role to
screen like that and then what was maybe
something you could do without doing
something new
working with Andy again for me
unlike Rohan and Andy who had to go make
a whole live-action film as well as
doing all the performance capture
section I just actually the performance
capture so I just sort of jumped in for
three days every year and a half or
something did that so far more intense
quickly but then well you're at your
stepping away from it's a very different
rhythm for me in terms of working and
hard things just getting used to not
getting your cameras jammed up and
caught up with other actors which is
sort of just the sign of the amateur
that I was when I started I think I
don't want to see b-roll of that out
[Music]
you